hi my name is girly I'm a consultant for
Wolfram research and I'm giving a talk
on the computer-based math and how it
works in the cloud
hey hello good morning my name's curly
I'm going to be talking to you about
computer-based math this is this is an
initiative that is originated from the
UK hence the plural plural at the end of
the maths there and I'm going to be
talking about CBM compute C BM and how
it how it currently works and how we got
it to work in the cloud so just to start
off with a short little background into
what is CBM in the first place so CBM is
a kind of initiative to redo maths
education so kind of current maths is
very sort of calculating based it's very
you know let's do let's Han calculate
let's you know figure out all the
technical details and the CPM initiative
is really more about you know let's do
more of a thinking let's do more of the
let's have students do more of the
problem-solving let's do the translation
from a from the problem to something
that a computer can understand and then
the translation from what the computer
gives you back into human language and
so the things that I'm going to be
showing you are the materials that we
have built to help you know help do this
in the classroom so we have these
modules and that we've created where we
start start out with a question so for
example how happy are people in my
country and then we try and answer that
question so we don't we don't start with
you know you have your this is how you
calculate square roots this is how you
solve these equations we start with a
question and then we introduce the tools
that are necessary to to solve it but
I'm not going to go a lot more into the
details about what is the kind of idea
of this I'm going to be talking more
about the technical details of how we
build these modules how they work and
desktop how they work on the cloud ok so
as I said we have we have built these
modules we have built these kind of
structured documents that guide the
student through a through answering a
question so there is a way for you to
try this out I will have these links on
the summary slide as well and they're
all available for you to
you know after the conference you can
see the you can get a notebook you can
get all these things so you don't have
to hurry it up down you can try this out
on desktop for yourself as well we have
a link on the CBM website for
downloading a module so this is for
desktop use so this is our current
delivery mechanism so we've been we've
had prototypes out for in quite a few
years now and the delivery mechanism has
been a desktop-based so this one
specifically is if you have Mathematica
installed already but we do have
versions that work with Wolfram player
on desktop as well and the way these the
desktop client has been structured is
that we've we've built this as a pack
that ORS an application that can it
contains notebooks so notebooks CD f's I
guess nowadays they're basically the
same we also have a custom style sheet
here's a little screenshot of how it
looks like it will open it up as well
there are various packaged files that we
include as well so it is quite a big
sort of there's quite a lot of
infrastructure that we've built to make
these make these materials you know be
be nice and interactive and have no look
look beautiful all sorts and all sorts
of other things we also include image
and data resources so we didn't want to
include quite everything in the file
itself the notebook files would get big
and some things you know we kind of want
to allow different data resources to
come in so we do include quite a lot of
files in the layout so the reason I
talked about this while we built it up
on desktop is that all of this we have
now had to make work in the cloud as
well and I will get to what the cloud
how we've kind of made all of these
files work together in the cloud in just
a bit
but first let me actually open up open
up what the CBN materials look like on
desktop so we deliver this with with an
installer so that installer creates that
desktop shortcut as well so which will
fire up this welcome screen so this is a
mathematical palette so as you noticed I
opened up it opened it up from the
it's menu and this is kind of like a
single entry on desktop like we assumed
that everyone will come in through this
welcome screen you know they can log-in
so we've built this kind of
collaboration framework we have a server
as well I'll talk about that a little
bit and then make it open up pumping up
a module so the one I'm going to show
here is this this is the one that we
have we're prototyping on the cloud as
well and it's this this is a slideshow
notebook right so it has it has quite a
lot of so we have some summary slides
and so this one specifically here is a
teacher version it has a lot of these
kind of orange boxes here four so I
don't want to get into a whole lot of
detail about you know the kind of
structure of these I kind of just want
to focus on the technical technical
details really so I'm gonna skip over a
lot of what at what these things are so
let me just open up a student version
yes the student version and the way that
the you know when a student opens up
this module what they will see is you
know they will have some introductory
text about what's going on they have
some where is this scroll down please
and of course it's not opening okay so
they have this notebook that has a lot
of text about what's going on they have
these interactive questions so you'll
see there's a send button here so we can
connect to a server you can answer
questions you can send this to to the
server the teacher can pull all these
answers and show them on their screen
there are these you know their example
data here so there are quite a lot of
these let me try and click on this
button a lot of dynamic interactive
elements that we've built as well to
help help students explore different
data different sort of methods of things
that they can use these are all things
that we've got working in the cloud as
well but just to kind of give you an
overview of what's going on so here is
an you know example of an example
question where you can kind of drag
things into the right place and then it
will go ahead and check your answers for
you so again this so this is this is
something that can be used
a you know in a teacher-led environment
this is something that can be used in a
student just goes and kind of studies
this on their own we have self checking
answers self checking questions etc etc
let me just find a link somewhere here
as well so this is just one notebook
here currently this is a module notebook
we also have these things called primers
that will help you you know just go into
a bit more detail about some specific
some specific tools so for example what
is it statistic what sort of things are
interested in what what sort of things
are relevant for what to watch out for
you know what is it what are link tools
some sort of things to help you learn
this this tool this concept a bit better
but again here like on desktop these are
separate separate notebook files and
we've all like when we've delivered this
this kind of this package of CPM
materials like we've just bundled all of
this together and the Installer puts
them in the right place and we have
something you know tools that the well
there's you can use white file or
something like that that knows where to
find these files relative to where you
have installed them now so that that is
the the desktop version of the of the
materials that we have now how do I get
back to mess I mentioned that yes we
have all these notebooks we have a style
sheet so you notice that this is not
this this is a standard Mathematica
notebook it's just that we have we have
quite heavily added styles on top of it
to have it to give it you know well very
well and if ur n't
to kind of you know the Olie styles are
intended to kind of help emphasize the
right things and make it look visually
pleasing as well so you know it does
look pretty and very very happy with
that so that's the client site we also
have a server so I briefly mentioned
that we have these questions you can you
have users can log in they can answer
questions which get sent to a server
that then you know
teacher can pull in answers from that
server and you know show these you know
do analysis and that show these to the
class etc that server we have built with
uses a very kind of large stack of
materials we have technologies we do use
Mathematica and web Mathematica for this
currently and we're using it you know
JSP fast and URL execute from within the
client to then call back to the server
so the server I'm not going to go into a
lot of detail today because for the
cloud version we didn't need to do
anything with the servers that the
server is you know that's living
somewhere cephalic the cloud client can
call the server just as well as I can
from desktop so but just to kind of note
that this is also we have this client
that calls out to something something on
the outside as well so it's not just
localized now on to the cloud version so
there is a there is a link here where
you can actually go and open it and try
it out yourself so this is deployed
currently under my own account this is
this is distributed as a developer
preview so this is not an official an
official release of any way we are
currently still kind of you know still
figuring out a few little kind of how do
we distribute this a few little kind of
bugs of bugs that you know related to
just kind of moving to a different
delivery platform so it was round slash
CPM cloud preview if you want to try it
out but ya know hub thing something
links on the final summary page and this
looks essentially the same as the
version that we had on desktop so one
kind of one difference here is that we
this thing includes these little videos
so this one this version is intended for
self-study as well so we've had Alec
here who is the CBM Content Manager he
has recorded these videos to help you
kind of you know make better sense of
what's going on help you you know if
there have been any answers any
questions that you've had to answer
explain what's you know why some answers
were the thing worth we're like that etc
so there are these little things
I've included here as well module let's
go a few pages ahead and you can see
that like this is so this is a slideshow
notebook and you can see that it really
kind of works quite well so let me do it
example data here let me just choose a
random boy and girl so just you know
dynamic interactive content that they
can explore just works on the cloud it's
beautiful so here we had this I had a so
some content does take a little bit
longer to load so one of the challenges
that we faced with getting this content
from desktop to the cloud is that we
were very dynamic heavy so we have a lot
of interactive content and on desktop
you know all of this we built we built
first on desktop and then we moved to
the cloud which is you know not the
ideal way of doing things so we were
kind of you know just used to things
like you know communication between a
front end and the kernel being
instantaneous which may not be true on
on cloud for example there is a kind of
longer round-trip that is required so
you know because we've that's that's
kind of but because we have the desktop
at first that's kind of what we thought
we've been doing but you know overall it
does work you know pretty much the same
you know here's the great I don't know
what happens as usual in the demo um so
here's another one that is a you know
kind of drag-and-drop that you can just
drag around I think does it show that
the some of these are green some of
these are red so which happened dragged
to the correct place which haven't been
dragged to the correct place you know
it's just I think there's just like the
tiniest bit more sort of lag between you
know when you click a button and
something happens but it's all I think
all with and perfectly reasonable
response times and so that's that's the
version on the cloud now another thing
so I opened up this this primer on so
this this primer file and us up as well
so let me open it up on on cloud
and again you can see we just have these
kind of links between notebooks that
kind of you know I'll just work and this
this can this can link back to other
primers etc etc now to talk briefly
about kind of some general differences
that we found when we were doing this
transition from desktop to cloud so in
the desktop version we have a very
specific entry method into the tool so
we say you know either you go have a
shortcut that takes you to the pallet or
you go into Mathematica palettes open
the CBM palette and that's the first
thing you see and so that palette then
has all sorts of things that it does it
loads in package files so it does all
sorts of initialization that we because
we know that this is where the student
will come in or the teacher will come in
we know stuff will be handled their
initialization will be handled there any
other file they open that can rely on
code files being loaded with the cloud
and that's not the case a student can go
ahead and bookmark any of these pages
individually they can come in from
wherever we can't really you know there
is no single entry route because we have
a different all these different pages
that that they can they can they can
view and they can come into so we are we
are still kind of figuring out some some
initialization issues are related to
that we haven't quite fine this is also
one of the reasons why there's no
official release of this yet is that
currently if you do if you don't you
have to open through hoping the module
file first for everything to work
correctly
so you know just so you everywhere it
doesn't work it doesn't always it
doesn't all work but we know what we
have to do in order to get and to get
there yet another issue is that you can
assume you can assume nothing you have
no idea what what the user has in their
machine with this desktop version like
we know that they came in they installed
they installed this CP n materials these
CV materials which placed a certain
packets in certain places certain files
in certain places and we know they're
there we know where they are
well we're know roughly where they are
and then when we open this open the open
the CBN materials we can just go please
load in the CPM Pacolet and everything
will just work here we can assume
nothing this the user can go in so go
and go to this webpage they have nothing
on their account so we do we do have so
you might have noticed here that I have
opened this this is the product view
this is not a deployed view so we do
want the students to be able to kind of
edit these files so you could they can
go and go in here create copies of these
notebooks from this for themselves add
code edit code so we wanted them to be
you know have an experience like in
Mathematica but it's not quite the same
as in Mathematica because they come in
with a clean mathematical sort of like a
clean Mathematica installation and so
that's that's kind of something that we
had to then work out is how to how to
pull in pull in the necessary code live
when they open the notebook without
knowing where they're coming from where
this file lives etc another thing is
that we we don't know where this where
this file lives so we said we we want
the user to go in and create their a
copy of their own but that means we
can't we can't assume that you know next
to that notebook there will be some
other file that we can then conveniently
load in we need to so we can't really
use relative paths to to find other
files another thing that the user can do
is they can download this notebook and
suddenly we're not living on the cloud
at all but we still want everything to
continue working and it does if you
download that notebook everything will
still continue working so a few
specifics when loading in the Pacolet
when loading in the code that is
necessary for that module to run on the
desktop we can just go load in the main
CP impacted and load in the Mojo
specific pack that goat and then
Mathematica knows okay so since we've
placed these files in the correct
location in this user base applications
or base directory applications
everything will be just found on the
cloud for exam
cannot do this so on the cloud what
we've done is actually we've hard-coded
into the module go directly do this URL
and this is where you will find the
packet and the reason well this sort of
system does work if you just put if you
install a packet under your own cloud
account and then your that user that
goes in at loads in the code but if you
have if you create if another user who
has not deployed this notebook who
doesn't have these packets installed in
their account this thing doesn't really
mean anything you know the cloud
Mathematica does not know where to go to
find these files so what we've done is
just said that you know this is where
the CPM packet packet so we have gone
and you know directly gone into the load
that you mean in a dot M file to get the
packet so there is a show you what that
I thought I could show you about that in
it and M file looks like but I think my
mother matica just died so that's fine
is this the right where you sorry about
that
I mean not show you how that looks like
but anyway that in it that I'm file
usually urinator that in file will
contain similar sorts of statements it
will be get packaged back to accept
package etc but we do just say a bunch
of different Lodha file from this
location load a file from this location
of load a file from this location a note
that we're not using cloud objects here
the reason that we've done that is
because if you if you if you download
this cloud file and you want to open it
locally if you do a gift of a cloud
object there's some interference with
what your current dollar cloud base is
set to so if you're someone who works
with private clouds or some other sort
of test environments where you might not
just use the public cloud this kind of
ensures that you know there's a specific
URL that it goes to it doesn't it
doesn't kind of you know that fall has
been set to be publicly available it's
executable you can load it there's no
need to kind of interfere with a cloud
object and the system so yeah another
thing to know
it's not if you set your if if you're
just a permission permissions to public
that's not gonna give it execute
privileges so you can't I think you
can't correct me if I'm wrong but I
think you then you can't easily just
load in the run the code so you have to
explicitly give it execute privileges as
well for it to work
this will set up a while ago so maybe
some things have changed but this is
what we kind of needed to do to make
sure that you can actually then you know
run the code reloading the code so it
executes yeah another thing I mentioned
is that we're not using deployed view
we're using product view so one thing
that you might have noticed here is that
so in the current integration of the
cloud this is business rule for several
versions now there's this either slash
obj or slash EMV so all the notebooks
for example these open in product view
so we've happened we have this be here
so if you saw if you change that end to
option that will give you a deployed
view but we wanted to open in product
view at least all the notebooks we want
to open like they open in Mathematica
but online rather than whereas all these
code files we do these do come in like
sort of like in deployed view this is
the so if I if I copy this and go and
but this will download the file so this
is like the the ax you know that is the
actual location of the file it doesn't
have any whereas if I change it to this
env you open like you've opened a
package file on desktop mathematic as
well so it will open you can see the
code and stuff like that another thing
that so because I'm the user of I'm the
owner of that file so I just kind of you
know when I clicked that link it just
opened to open like it would if you were
to go to that link and say and open it
up you would get a little dial you get a
little bar at the top saying you're
viewing you know would you like to
create a local copy of this notebook and
so we have this auto auto copy property
set as well and the idea is that once
you and once we have it properly set up
the CBM account which deploys this that
will just automatically create this copy
for you so kind of like explorations
notebooks currently you know if
there they have been deployed by the
some local internal account but if you
go and open a new exploration it will
just automatically equate it create a
new notebook for you and that's kind of
the similar sort of thing we want to do
I'm going to do here as well and then a
few other changes that we want we made
to make sure that everything loads when
on desktop when on cloud when you
download it is to say that we embedded
the staff sheet on desktop we have a
link to an extra in a file that has all
the styles here if you actually if you
download the file and go file you know
edit edit socket you can see all the
fancy styles that we put in another
thing that we we do is yes we use direct
URLs for all sorts of things so so you
know you're all off quite like this so
we don't rely on this being on a nice
pink because the file lives that CBM
slash content something something so we
can't really say you know just open
something you know topped up some other
files we put in these full password this
is where this code file lives this is
where this this image file live so any
sort of data resources that come in and
all sorts of linked notebooks as well so
this these these links here that will
kind of open up what this one doesn't
have any link primers but this one here
these have you know explicit this is the
link that will open and this is you know
we have build processes that kind of
automatically be transformed or you know
deploy to desktop content to to cloud
content and that kind of turns that
relative linking that we do on tests up
into an absolute linking that we do on
cloud you know if you don't have such a
system then kind of you know you have to
have to make sure of that yourself and
then yes noting here as well that all of
this ensures that when you download the
notebook everything still works as
intended and this has actually given us
a new way of distributing desktop
content as well because suddenly we
don't need to distribute this entire
packet system we can just have
everything all the all the code and
everything that we needed just be
downloaded from cloud from the cloud
line it does have a it does have a sort
of a small penalty in the initial
startup time and that you know because
it has to then download the files before
it can load them so it is still you know
furball to just have everything
pre-installed things open up a bit
faster but you know
desperate times then they can work as
well and then just a list of a few
things that you might be interested in
knowing that just worked we didn't need
to do anything that you know they kind
of just they work in the cloud so we
could we could do slideshows we did
consider going for this MOOC format this
like that Wolfram you uses so we would
split all the slides into separate pages
and kind of do that but we kind of just
ended up going with this slideshow
notebook and it works pretty well
front end tokens Doc's are at the top so
here this one here loads this is a dot
cells you can see it's kind of sticks
out the top there works perfectly fine I
didn't open any dialogues but for
example just look at this we have this
login dialog that opens quite quite
quite nicely on on cloud as well so
that's the summary of how CBM works on
the cloud here are examples for if you
want to go ahead and try them out and
feel free to reach out if you have any
comments or questions thank you
[Applause]